DAVE LOWRY ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PLAY WITH GOT KYLE CONNOR NE
NET.
BUT
WILL GET IT DOWN LOW.
PLAY CATCH AND PIERRE-LUC
HARKINS-CONNOR LINE OUT LED BY
DUBOIS.
>> Sam: YOU LIVE BY THE SWORD
YOU
FIRED INTO THE FLYERS' ZONE BY
>> Harnarayan: NIKOLAJ EHLERS
ALSO ADDING TO TH GET TO 50.
JUST A COUPLE GAMES LEFT TOM MAK
CARE OF THE REBOUND IN FRONT OF
HIM.
FLYERS DISAPPOINTED IN THE WAY
THINGS HAVE GONE.
ALL THETTING OUT
ALONE. AMAZING WHEN YOU
THINK THEEK ON
THE ICE.
BACK TO EVEN STRENGTH AS BACKHA.
PENALTY AGAIN UPCOMING AGAINST
THE FLYERS.
[W[W MORRISSEY.
POWER PLAY
AND IT GOT AWAY FROM HIM.
KYLE CONNOR,SSESSION.
CONNOR DOES A GOOD JOB GETTING
IT TO EHLERS AND UNLOADS THEON
BRAKES.
HIS COURSE AND THAT CREATED
REALLY POPULAR.
VERY EASY FOR THESE
>> Sam: LOTS OF ACTION HERE AS
WE GO SANDSTROM GOT JUST ENOUGH
OL' BETWEEN THE LEGS TRICK.
OPPORTUNITY FOR NIKOLAJ EHLERS.
PASS IN IED THIS TIME.
EHLERS GOES WIDE AND THAT
THEY BATTLE AT T TIME
FINAL 60 SECONDS OF THE SECOND .
AS THE THIRD PERIOD IS ABOUT TO
FARABEE.R WAY.
LOOKING TO  TO BE A CLEAN SAVE
HIT BY SANFORD.365
IS THE WORLD'S FAVOURITE SPORTS
BOOK.
HE GETS IT TO ATTARD. BLOCKED
BY SANFORD.
NOW LOWRY.
SANFORD TO APPLETON.
>> Sam: THE PUCK BACK FROMSPOTS.
TIPPETT SHOOTS.
COMRIE Sam: EXACTLY THE REASON
OUT THERE.